okay so when you have a look at this I'm
going to think about some particular
areas that relate to sign and 10 and X
okay so if we call this actually in the
call of theta I should call it X like I
having my heading okay if we call this
angle X I'm going to think about three
areas in succession and you can see them
on this diagram okay so the very first
one is this triangle here which has X in
it here's the first area I'm interested
in okay now I've chosen this as an
arbitrary circle so let's make the
radius R okay it's their event now I
have a look at the triangle and have a
look at the information that you have
what is the area of this green triangle
you don't have a basement a height that
are perpendicular to each other so
you're gonna have to use the trig result
for the area of a triangle right which
is half a B sine C right except these
are your am your B and this is your C
its the included angle so everything
goes key so in this case I'm gonna use
my migraine okay
the area of the triangle this is the
little triangle is going to be 1/2 R
squared there's my a and my B sine X in
this case that's the included angle is
that okay all right so far so good
that's my area that's connected to sone
okay I'm gonna think about a new area
now I'm not gonna color all the way over
it because otherwise I'd ruin my wiper
markers and this should become a rainbow
disaster but I'm going to consider
taking that triangle you just worked out
and adding this little strip it's a
segment isn't it if I add those together
what shape is this total colored figure
this is called ah it starts with an S
slice of pizza it's a sector right to
sect up so what I'm going to do is work
out the area of this hole it looks sort
of like that
that's sector okay now we just
established a formula for this right
what is the area of a sector now that
you know your Radian measure stuff I'll
give you a clue it starts
remarkably similar to this yeah it's
gonna be a half R squared theta whatever
your angle happens to be my feet are in
this case is X okay now let me just
pause here to point out these two are
connected right do you see that no
matter what X you chose no matter what X
you chose this sector is bigger than
this triangle do you agree like the
sector includes the triangle every
single time so the sector will be a
teeny bit bigger than the triangle are
you ok with that idea ok there's one
more area I've got X I've got sine I'm
looking for Tim okay now where is 10
well think about this diagram that I had
before right and what Y 10 has its name
and have a look at the diagram where do
you think we might find 10 what feature
do you think might be relevant what's
what's 10 short for again tangent and
what do you see in this diagram a
tangent right so I'm gonna use this
whole big triangle here that's based off
of this tangent okay so I'm gonna now
color it in this guy over here so now
I'm considering the whole lot it's the
area of I'm gonna draw it like this
because that's its shape this big
triangle here and I know that it's
right-angled how do I know that it's
right angle think back to last year the
tangent the tangent is perpendicular to
the radius at the point of contact
you're great okay now this is kind of
handy because if it's perpendicular then
this can be the base of the triangle and
this would be the height so I have a
formula for that right the only catch is
I don't know what the height is in this
case okay so I want you to think back to
yesterday when we derived the trig
expansion for sine a plus B right do you
remember we had a look at all these
different lengths in the diagram and we
found them in terms of trig ratios sines
and cosines and all that kind of thing
so I want you to have a look this is the
side I'm after over here again
you've got some clues what can I write
that will help me get to an expression
for the length of this side a good clue
is to start with Ted all right I'm just
gonna write it over here as rough
working the only angle that I have in
this case is the X so 10x well I can
even though I said let's get away from
this I can still use all of these
definitions they still work right so tan
is going to be that's our X's then this
is opposite on adjacent this is my
mystery side on top of my radius which
is right beside me right so what's my
mystery side going to be it's gonna have
a look I'm just gonna multiply across by
our right so this is gonna be aa tan X
are you okay with that you see I've just
multiplied both sides okay so now you
can tell me what's the area of this big
right-angled triangle that encapsulates
everything yeah half because the formula
for the every triangle with this is 1/2
base times height my bases are my height
is that so there's an R and then there's
another R and then there's potato okay
now now you point out two more things
remember how we said this sector must
include this triangle and be a little
bit bigger remember that this sector
includes this triangle and is a little
bit bigger well the same thing is
happening with this big red triangle do
you notice that like it goes outside the
circle so it must be bigger than the
sector yeah
so in fact what I can establish is this
set of inequalities this is why I've
done it in this particular order I've
started from the smallest shape on my
diagram and I've just gotten bigger and
bigger and bigger are you with me is
that okay the second thing I want to
point out is this formula right here in
the middle right it relies on the fact
that X must be in radians do you agree
with that like that was we could only
start using this formula for the area
sector once we learnt what radians were
okay so all of this early functions in
radians so I'm just gonna actually put
that it's so important and I'll come
back to bite you later I'm going to put
this right up the top it's
only in radians okay because if you were
in radians that would not be the area of
a sector right you can't just put in
like 30 degrees you'd get an enormous
number okay you put PI on six or
something like that okay
now we're trying to get to this
relationship right sine X tan X and X
okay well I can just get those by
themselves if I get rid of all this
extra fluff around right see you've got
this constant hanging around I'm going
to divide everything through by that but
just a caution you know we're dealing
with inequalities here right so you know
when you divide or multiply by things
when you deal with inequalities you have
to be careful about the sign what will
happen to the direction of these
inequalities when I divide through by
half a square Thea what will happen well
the with the inequalities change
direction or not they will not what's
the reason why two reasons at least its
squared so it's positive but also it's a
radius it was positive to begin with
okay so I'm definitely divided by
something positive so what I'm getting
is this sine X is gonna be less than X
which is going to be less than 10x okay
how you feeling all right now this is
really good but it hasn't quite gotten
us to what I was wanting my intuition
was that these things they all behave
the same way when X is small and I've
got a relationship between them that's
something but I don't quite have it
saying that